the sushi science show clips
and one thing I just wanted to quickly
ask you before I forget since you
mentioned about fertility and has have
you seen any of your studies any link
between n80 plus
um like uh levels and fertility because
I know there's a lot of underneath about
in the fertility crisis yeah yeah we
basically started
um you know this
the the connection with with Women's
Health and Family Health in um an
experiment that we published in 2019
it's ear
um at all and
um in cell reports and
um you can see in the supplementary
figure that we did an experiment with
um
that we did two initial experiments and
one didn't work very well and one was
amazing and so we went with amazing and
then we have a kind of a follow-up but
we wanted to look at the ability of
nicotinoide riboside to
um
you know promote uh fertility in
overweight and metabolically challenged
black six mice so they were on a high
fat diet
and then tried to get them pregnant with
and without an r and there was there
were basically only one you know term
pregnancy and it was in
high fat with NR and high fat with NR
high fat without NR couldn't even get
the mice pregnant but you can't do a lot
of analysis when you have one
you know litter
of a supplemented mom and no litters of
non-supplemented moms and you know it's
just so there was that's in a 2019 paper
that NR might be helping Mom get
pregnant particularly if she has
metabolic challenges
but what happened in the normal Chow
side was really amazing you think of
mouse Chow as being very nutritious
stuff
and it has all the vitamins that it's
supposed to have in it it's been
formulated it has B3 equivalence in it
and yet the mice that were given
additional nicotinamide riboside did
much better they had
um
uh they they're
during the course of their uh
being co-housed with the pops which is
basically the nursing period
um the the mice were uh bigger and more
resilient if the mom was NR supplemented
and the moms lost weight and that were
able to attribute that to Greater milk
production
and it turned out to be linked to
um a better
neurodevelopmental
time course for The Offspring and not
only did their motor skills Advance
better if Mom was supplemented
but their whole life trajectory was
better and their body composition was
better
um at three months which is a very much
of uh of an adult uh rodent and so uh
they they could be they could be they
could be bigger at weaning and then they
could be leaner as adults it was quite
remarkable and they had better you know
motor learning skills and uh
Morris water maze performance and
they had lower anxiety scores if you
believe Mouse anxiety scores and so it
was it was quite an amazing thing and
now a lot of other people do are doing
things with with with with with NAD
boosting in in maternal Health as well
that's really interesting um so you just
looked at females right oh was there any
did you look at spam counts and Mel's or
anything it was just females I don't
think that our group has done
um sperm count
um that that could be interesting as
well yeah you could come and do it
um I mean reproductive aging is really
really interesting so yeah and it's
something that that it's that there's
very unique features of it in in human
um like the existence of menopause right
so you know a woman half or a woman's
lifetime is beyond her
um
age of reproductive capability that that
I think is because human babies are so
inept at getting their own food and and
being able to be you know protected from
predation that in human evolution we
needed not only mothers but grandmothers
but um so uh so there's some rapidly
involving evolving genes that relate to
to aging
um and then the difference between male
and female is interesting as well yeah I
was about to ask you is there any sex
specific differences just in any of
these
um NL studies that you've done
in terms of like efficacy I guess
not so much that we've done I have to
say that our first high fat thing
um was a male only isn't that terrible
and and
um and then we did the whole then we did
this thing that was all female
and oh but we did look at the pup
um scores and there were male and female
differences in a number of the of the
figures I can't cite you every single
difference but there were some
differences yeah okay but this you think
of something that we should probably pay
more attention to like going on are you
sure okay I sure am now yeah